Davis is with us in Raleigh hi Davis how
are you I'm fine mr. Ramsey how are you
doing
better than I deserve what's up all
right so I have 21,000 $140 debt just
under 15,000 in the bank I have a
vintage car worth 4,500 and I can sell
personal assets up to 2 grand
I had a high-end engine business that I
was running but I had to shut down uh
due to the fact that I had been scammed
once and been lied to right after that
all which helped which made me build up
this debt I have been leveraging the
engine via debt with my brother which
looking back on it was a very poor
decision agreed wondering since I'm
struggling to pay back this debt as you
can tell I'm kind of young um how do you
think that I should eat assigned settle
this or you know settle some of it off
while paying some of it with my brother
and still maintain a healthy
relationship with him
because you owe your brother the fifteen
thousand I do I owe my brother no no I
mean twenty one thousand one hundred
forty dollars right I owe fist
fifteen hundred to my dad and the rest
of my brother okay and you have $15,000
cash in the bank right okay and the vent
how old are you I'm fourteen fourteen
yes yes sir and how old is your brother
he's 16 dude do you know how weird this
sounds I know it sounds crazy uh but
I've just you know I've been always done
entrepreneurial things but just I
started looking into debt and this was
before I got to you and I thought I
could build the business in for a while
it was working but where was like how
far that did not allow you to go fifteen
$21,000 in the debt to your brother
who's 16 when you're 14 where's your
father I want to buy his ears well he
was uh he was he's very or he's pretty
angry understandably
now I he stood there and allowed it to
go on I don't have 14 year olds doing
$21,000 transactions under my roof and I
don't know what the flips going on okay
take the 15,000 out of the bank and pay
your father the 1500 I guess he should
probably be penalized more than 1500 for
being a doofus as a dad
but um anyway pay him the 1500 and pay
the rest of your brother's sell your
vintage car and I think your brother's
paid off then right all right yeah yeah
you don't need a vintage car when you're
14 anyway not a lot you can do with all
right and it's probably over it's
probably older than you are
so yeah just get rid of it and clean up
this mess and learn the lesson and dude
I got to tell you this is a weird call
I'll just be I'll just be truthful with
you you understand it's awesome that you
could be involved in a business that was
that big a deal at 14 but for your
parents to allow this kind of disaster
to occur under their roof to their own
child is irresponsible and I'll just say
that out loud just so you can hear me
and your dad can hear me he can be
pissed at me later this is the Dave
Ramsey show open foam is a triple eight
eight two five five two two five listen
you want to let your teenagers
experience the pain of their bad
decisions but not with them ease zeros
on it I mean I want them to make a bad
decision and have to fix something
that's a thousand dollars or five
hundred bucks they got to work their way
out of it it's a real pain and it costs
them half their summer because they made
some bad decisions that kind of stuff
I want my teens to make decisions and
have the results of the decisions land
on their head that's called being a
grown-up and it's me teaching them to be
a grown-up but I don't put that many
zeros on the end of it to where that a
kid is hung out to dry at that level and
so Wow
that's just astronomical so yeah yeah
those of you wanting to teach your teens
and for that matter preteens how to
handle money smart money smart kids is
how we raised ours that's the book the
Rachel Cruise and I wrote together that
we raised our kids with and we allowed
them to experience the pain
they're stupidness but not at not with
the zeros on the end like that I mean we
want them to feel the pain and we wanted
to be entrepreneurial and understand
what risk feels like and all that but oh
my goodness I thought I was talking to a
25 year old this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind